i think it's extremely clear that's the
day i was born i've only loved adored
and supported my sister
i mean this is my freaking big sister
before any of the spoils
jamie lynn spears is breaking her
silence after her sister britney
spears's explosive conservatorship
hearing i am now ready to tell the story
on monday the 30 year old actress went
on instagram to tell her side of the
story
saying that she 100 percent supports her
older sister
she also hit back at those criticizing
her for not
speaking out sooner maybe i didn't
support her the way the public would
like me to
with a hashtag on a public platform but
i can assure you that i've supported my
sister
long before there was a hashtag and i'll
support her long after jamie lynn also
said the only reason she had not spoken
out before
is because she wanted brittany to have
the opportunity to speak for herself
first i love her she's like she's 10
years younger than me but she's like
so stubborn and she's like so headstrong
and she makes me laugh she's
hilarious the former zoe 101 star
also said she has only loved and adored
brittany her entire life
and she's proud of her sister for
telling her truth
my sister knows i love and support her
that's the only person i owe anything to
i'm not my family i'm my own person i'm
speaking for myself
i'm so proud of her for using her voice
jamie said that she supports ending
britney's conservatorship
if that's what she wants if ending the
conservatorship
flying to mars or whatever the hell else
she wants to do
to be happy i support that 100 percent
because i support my sister i love my
sister always have always will
as long as she's happy jamie lynn's
husband jamie watson
also defended brittany while showing
support for the spears family
he told the new york post quote i can
assure you her family loves her and
wants the best for her
i wouldn't be around people who weren't
who wouldn't want to be in support of
brittany
during britney's bombshell statements
against her conservatorship
on wednesday she slammed her famous
family at the hearing the pop star
accused her father jamie spears
and those involved for criminal behavior
and called the conservatorship
abusive and stupid brittany even said
quote
i want to sue my family to be totally
honest with you
this marked the first time in years that
britney spoke in court about the
conservatorship
which she's been in since 2008 and the
first time ever that her remarks were
made public
and regardless with what happens next
jamie lynn speer says she will also
defend her big sister
my sister knows i love and support her
that's the only person i owe anything to
i'm not my family i'm my own person i'm
speaking for myself